I'm here with Matt from Matt it's so good to have you here.
>> It's great to be here.
You know I I came here to two things.
Chew bubble gum and talk about graphing and I'm all out of bubble gum.
[LAUGH] So, excited to be here.
>> Great so tell us, what is >> So we're a graphic and analytics platform and
the idea behind it has been that we want really two things.
One is for anyone at any level of tech, technical sophistication to be
able to make a really pretty interactive and collaborative graph.
So in the same way that you might make graphs, you know,
with Google Docs, or you know, editing documents with Google docs,
we want people to be able to edit and analyze data and make graphs there online.
And we'd like that to be something that's useful for high schoolers and
then also all the way up to folks who are working on technical and
sophisticated projects that we have corporations and
folks at the Washington Post who are using it too.
So first part is anyone at any level making and sharing graphs.
And then the second part is being able to have it be a hub for your data and
your graphs and your code and your collaboration.
So typically when you make a graph, you have some data and then you analyze it,
and then you use either code or maybe a program like Excel or
Tableau to make your graph.
And then you email about it.
So you have to put all of those things into an email or into you know,
shared folder.
And then other people kind of have to look at it locally and
check out the data themselves.
But for us we've tried to make it so, that all of that happens off code,
graph, data, and collaboration all in one place.
And it happens between languages.
So you can add a graph with any language or just a web app.